[Música]
ciudadanos franceses se rebelan
nuevamente contra la violencia policial
un nuevo vídeo que muestra la paliza de
cuatro policías a un hombre negro bajo
continuado en insultos racistas ha
desatado una nueva jornada de protestas
en todo el país
en parís miles de personas han marchado
desde la céntrica plaza de la república
hasta la plaza de la bastilla
lo que está pasando en francia me parece
muy preocupante grave no podemos
permitir que esto suceda pase dos años
con los chalecos amarillos y de toda la
violencia que se podía ver y debo decir
que me pregunto mucho y lo he hecho
durante mucho tiempo cuantos michelle
han sido encerrados de vida
declaraciones policiales fraudulentas
todo tras el desalojo violento de un
campo de refugiados en la plaza de la
república de parís el pasado 23 de
noviembre y la polémica por la nueva ley
de seguridad global del gobierno de
macrón que pretende penar la difusión
mal intencionada de imágenes policiales
[Música]
hoy sólo hay una respuesta para
apaciguar al país no es sólo el retiro
del artículo 24 es el retiro de esta ley
es el retiro de este asalto a nuestras
libertades fundamentales
se necesita un dedo un dedo del
presidente teixidó pues la movilización
pacífica en parís se han quemado
contenedores y varios vehículos han
quedado calcinados la policía ha lanzado
gases lacrimógenos contra los
manifestantes
[Aplausos]